Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想快速告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, I am guiding you through two important steps that can help you think about weathering the storm on your journey
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。在今天这期《有抱负的心理学家》播客中，我将引导你完成两个重要的步骤，帮助你思考如何在旅途中应对风暴，
to becoming whatever type of aspiring psychologist you fancy being. Thank you. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. If you have been listening to the podcast for a little while, you might well recall the Pauli Wing series of episodes, which is where I was wearing my arm in a sling because I had recently broken my arm. I thought it was about time we did another little series. And this series is going to be called Marianne's Summer Soundbites. We're going to be looking at a series of important but smaller topics. This is a great way for you to stay on track with your psychology goals and commitment, even when you might be busier over the summer period.
从而成为你心目中想成为的那种心理学家。谢谢。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。如果你听这个播客有一段时间了，你可能还记得“Pauli Wing”系列节目，当时我因为刚摔断了手臂，所以一直戴着吊带。我觉得是时候做另一个小系列了。这个系列将被称为“Marianne的夏季短语”（Marianne's Summer Soundbites）。我们将探讨一系列重要但简短的话题。即使在夏季比较忙碌的时候，这也是让你保持心理学目标和承诺的绝佳方式。
All of these Marianne's Summer Soundbite episodes will just be me. But don't worry, this isn't a long-term change. The usual format of long episodes including guest episodes that I know you love will be back along in the autumn and there might also be some over the summer period too. So before we crack on let me guide you through another little series that is coming and again if you've been in my world a while you might well already know the free compassionate Q&A sessions they are absolutely free sessions I've been running live across all of my socials on
所有这些“Marianne的夏季短语”节目都将由我独自完成。但别担心，这并不是长期的改变。我所知道的你们喜欢的长篇节目（包括嘉宾访谈）将在秋季回归，夏季期间也可能会有一些。所以在我们开始之前，让我带你了解一下即将推出的另一个小系列。同样，如果你在我的圈子里待了一段时间，你可能已经知道免费的同情心问答环节了。这些是绝对免费的环节，我一直在我的所有社交媒体上进行直播，
weekday evenings during application and interview seasons and the great news is that they are back for the interview season and i've got the dates to share with you now so as you can see on your screen we have the first of those coming up on monday the 4th of september 2023 and that starts at 6 00 pm A replay will of course be available too and the best place to find the replay is Dr Marianne Trent on YouTube. The second of the sessions is Tuesday the 3rd of October 2023 also at 6pm. Again a replay is available. And the third and final session to support application season for the Declined Cyber also EdCycle is also a similar time of year is going to be Tuesday the 7th of November 2023
在申请和面试季节的平日晚上。好消息是，它们将在面试季回归，我现在就把日期分享给你们。正如你们在屏幕上看到的，第一个环节将在2023年9月4日星期一举行，时间是下午6点。当然也会有回放，找到回放的最佳地点是YouTube上的Dr. Marianne Trent。第二个环节是2023年10月3日星期二，同样是下午6点。同样会有回放。第三个也是最后一个支持申请季的环节，针对Declined Cyber和EdCycle（时间也差不多），将在2023年11月7日星期二举行，
at 6pm. So don't wait, don't delay, connect with me on socials now so that you can dive right in when the time comes. On LinkedIn I am Dr. Marianne Trent, come and connect or follow. On Twitter I am also Dr. Marianne Trent, although on Twitter I can't see your comments because StreamYard and Twitter don't integrate properly. But if you want to just watch from Twitter you absolutely can. On YouTube I am Dr. Marianne Trent. My Facebook page is also Dr. Marianne Trent. And last but of course not the least, come and join my free Facebook community group, which is called the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. I do always endeavour to get live on Instagram as well, but it's not quite so interactive because it means I have
下午6点。所以不要等待，不要拖延，现在就在社交媒体上关注我，这样当时间到来时，你就可以直接参与了。在LinkedIn上，我是Dr. Marianne Trent，来关注我吧。在Twitter上，我也是Dr. Marianne Trent，虽然在Twitter上我无法看到你们的评论，因为StreamYard和Twitter的集成有问题。但如果你想在Twitter上观看，完全没问题。在YouTube上，我是Dr. Marianne Trent。我的Facebook页面也是Dr. Marianne Trent。最后但同样重要的是，加入我的免费Facebook社区群组，名为“Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent”。我一直努力在Instagram上也进行直播，但互动性没那么强，因为这意味着我必须
to get my phone rigged up behind my webcam. It's a little bit rustic but you absolutely should be able to catch it there too and on Instagram and on threads I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. So come and follow me everywhere. Do a blanket approach, it would be much appreciated. So let's not wish the summer away, let's make it a really mindful and enjoyable one. Let's get back to Marianne's soundbites. So the first thing I would like you to consider and be mindful and aware of is just how much your passion matters. It can be really tricky on this aspiring psychologist journey to play the long game, to have a long burning, slow burning fuse where you hope that there will eventually be some spectacular
把手机架在网络摄像头后面。虽然有点简陋，但你绝对可以在那里看到直播。在Instagram和Threads上，我都是Dr. Marianne Trent。所以请在各个平台上关注我。采取全面覆盖的方法，我将不胜感激。所以，让我们不要虚度夏天，让我们过一个真正用心且愉快的夏天。让我们回到Marianne的短语。首先，我希望你考虑并意识到的是，你的热情有多重要。在成为心理学家的旅途中，坚持长期目标，保持那种缓慢燃烧的动力，并期待最终能有壮观且值得的烟花，这确实很棘手。
and worthwhile fireworks. During that time, it's really understandable and normal if your passion and commitment can feel like they wane or waver a little bit. Genuinely, from my own experiences, I felt that I always had my eye on that goal. And that was something I always wanted. And so, you know, my long term goal never, never did waver. And, you know, my commitment to ensuring that the clients I worked with had good, safe, effective service, ran throughout everything that I did and I'm sure the same is true for you too. If you feel like you're becoming a little bit less passionate, then make sure that you have taken your annual leave at regular
在那段时间里，如果你的热情和承诺感减弱或动摇，这是非常可以理解且正常的。真诚地说，根据我自己的经历，我感觉我一直盯着那个目标。那是我一直想要的。所以，你知道，我的长期目标从未动摇过。而且，我确保我合作的客户能获得良好、安全、有效的服务的承诺，贯穿了我所做的一切，我相信你也是如此。如果你觉得自己的热情有所减退，那么请确保你在一年中定期休了年假，
points throughout the year because when our passion disappears, it can be a sign an early indicator of burnout. Nobody does this job for the money and so really it is your dedication and your passion and commitment to having people's lives be more free from distress that is just incredible. Your determination to support their mental well-being is so admirable. Being able to make a meaningful, lasting impact upon people never gets old. So well done you. Your passion really does matter and I hope that it doesn't go unnoticed. Let's take a brief moment here to have a little sing-song and I'll be back with another of experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book.
因为当我们的热情消失时，这可能是倦怠的早期迹象。没有人是为了钱做这份工作，所以你致力于让人们的生活免受痛苦的奉献精神、热情和承诺是令人难以置信的。你支持他们心理健康的决心令人钦佩。能够对人们产生有意义、持久的影响永远不会过时。所以做得好。你的热情真的很重要，我希望它不会被忽视。让我们花点时间唱首歌，然后我会回来分享另一个能帮助你获得资格的经验。来看看吧，就在这本书里。
It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh
它是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。它是《临床心理学家集体》。它是《临床心理学家集体》。哦，哦，哦，哦，哦。
Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh
哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦。
Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh I do feel like perhaps we ought to have done a Summer Soundbites channel, but you know, make your own up And come back to me if you've come up with a good one I hope you found the first half of the first episode of Marianne's Summer Soundbites useful and thought-provoking What did it evoke for you? Do come and let me know in my free Facebook group The Aspiring Psychologist Community. The second of my musings for today is all about embracing your journey. Yes, yes, yes, I know. I know. It's the sort of thing that you get on the
哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦。我确实觉得也许我们应该做一个“夏季短语”频道，但你知道，自己编一个吧。如果你想到了一个好的，回来告诉我。希望你觉得“Marianne的夏季短语”第一集的前半部分有用且发人深省。它唤起了你什么感受？一定要在我的免费Facebook群组“Aspiring Psychologist Community”中告诉我。我今天的第二个思考是关于拥抱你的旅程。是的，是的，是的，我知道。我知道，这是那种你会写在笔记本封面上话，但我真的认为这非常重要。我们需要提醒自己，成为一名心理学家是一个过程，但可能会有转变，甚至是微小的、心理上的、内在的转变，你可能在日常生活中甚至没有注意到，但你肯定会在月复一月、年复一年中注意到，这将是带来改变的差异。我们真的必须能够拥抱学习机会、挑战，以及沿途那些感觉棘手的事情的成长。我们必须保持信念。你知道，你可能不是Bon Jovi的粉丝，但有一首歌叫《Keep the Faith》，我认为在这里很贴切。即使这很棘手，即使你可能经历过挫折，
front of a notebook, but I really do think it's really important. We need to remind ourselves that becoming a psychologist is a process, but there might well be shifts, even really tiny, you know, psychological shifts, internal shifts within ourselves that you might not even notice on a day-to-day basis, but you might certainly notice on a month-to-month and year-to-year basis that will be the difference that makes the difference. We really do have to be able to embrace the learning opportunities, challenges, the growth of things that feel tricky along the way. We have to keep the faith. You know, you might not be a Bon Jovi fan, but there's a song called Keep the Faith that I think is quite relevant here. Even though it's tricky, even though you might have had setbacks,
即使可能有些日子你觉得，啊，这真的很难，保持信念并继续朝着那个对你如此重要的目标前进是很重要的。如果它对你很重要，那么它就重要。你迈出的每一步都在让你更接近你想去的地方。如果你觉得不是这样，那么也许是时候通过新的主管或新的工作角色来做出改变了。永远记住，你可以从我的网站www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/supervision获取我免费的督导塑造工具。所以我希望你觉得我们“Marianne的夏季短语”播客系列的第一集很有用。如果你在成为临床心理学家的旅途中需要更多专家的关怀和指导，
even though there might have been days where you felt, ah, this is really hard, keeping the faith and keeping on heading towards that goal that's so important to you is important. If it matters to you, then it matters. Each and every step you take is bringing you closer to where you want to be. And if you feel that it's not, then maybe it's time for a shake-up with a new supervisor or a new job role. And always remember, you can come and grab my free supervision shaping tool from my website, www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision. So I hope you found the first in our series of Marianne's Summer Soundbite podcast episodes useful. If some more expert care and guidance in your journey towards becoming an aspiring clinical psychologist
可以考虑加入我们的“有抱负的心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），每月仅需30英镑，无需承诺。你可以通过访问我的网站或点击我任何社交媒体上的个人简介链接获取更多信息。如果你在YouTube上观看，也可以查看描述中的链接。在谈到YouTube时，如果你看了最近几集，你可能没注意到YouTube的感觉略有不同。有更多可看的内容，有更多的事情发生。不再仅仅是我和我的嘉宾在谈话。所以如果你有一段时间没看了，请前往YouTube上的Dr. Marianne Trent看看。当你在那里时，点赞、分享、评论、互动，做所有那些很棒的事情。非常感谢你在忙碌的一天中抽出时间收听这一集，
would be useful, do consider joining us in the Aspiring Psychologist membership from just £30 a month with no commitment. And you can get more information about that by going to my website or by clicking the bio link in any of my socials. If you're watching on YouTube, you can check out the links in the description too. And whilst we're talking about YouTube, you might not have noticed if you've watched the last few episodes that there's a slightly different feel to the YouTube. There's more to watch, there's more going on. It's not just me and my guests talking anymore. So if you haven't watched it for a while, do head over to Dr. Marianne Trent on YouTube and give it a while. And whilst you're there, like, share, comment, engage, do all those great things. Thank you so much for taking the time in your busy day to listen to this
并继续思考你的心理学目标、你的职业生涯，希望也包括你的个人和职业成长。我期待着在下一集《有抱负的心理学家》播客中与你见面，该节目将于周一早上6点播出。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将在获得资格的道路上。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康实习从业者。
episode and to keep thinking about your goals for psychology, for your career and hopefully also for your personal and professional growth too. I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast which will be along to you from 6am on Monday. Thanks for being part of my world. Take care. And let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Durant My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner
我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。